um
why I wanted to ask you about was how
you reacted when you saw news this month
about his family a legend that the band
uh and I think you're quite close to the
the singer the main singer Bob Gillespie
had abandoned him when he had an alcohol
problem they wrote quite a
quite a moving letter yeah I mean I saw
his son's letter and it was
heartbreaking but um you know you never
know what goes on within bands and um I
mean what I will say is that I must stop
you very much and it was you know it was
a great friend it was having a tough
time just before he died
um
remember he's at my wedding in last
August and he was he was very emotional
and uh I kind of we set up a record
company last year and kind of done it
and so I spent a lot in my studio was
done in Brighton and so I spent a lot of
time down there in the last few years
and it's just I miss him so much like
you know so it's uh
it's kind of um you know but anything
that happens Within
within a band or an organization is is
entirely therefore so it wouldn't be up
my business to talk about it because you
know you're only you're always operating
on limited knowledge but I will say this
the music industry is one of the most
horrible Industries it's um it's kind of
you know like the music industry film
industry in any creative industry it's
almost
um the industry part of it is the
antithesis of what the whole thing is
about and uh
that uh you know it's you just really
you don't know you don't know because
it's
um the politics of any kind of um
sort of band or label or whatever or
record company is completely
impenetrable to anybody from the outside
and um I mean nobody in in any in either
of these camps has kind of talked about
I mean I know the Duffy never talked
about it to me
I was actually surprised that you had
you seemed to have it was you know you
left or he was involved with the band
anymore I just didn't have you spoken to
Bobby about it I haven't spoken to
anybody about it no no do you think he's
been misrepresented or you just don't
know I don't know I I honestly I don't
have a clue it's quite sad isn't it the
whole it's very sad yeah because you
know it's like they'll also take these
guys like you know and um it's it's
always sad when it happens in a band